hello and welcome to swipe coming up
festive fun or seasonal stress our
gadgets changing how we enjoy Christmas
your own mini-me with the help of a 3d
printer we shrink one of Sky's reporters
ground control to Major Tom floating in
the most peculiar way singing astronaut
Chris Hadfield talks to swipe and
battles in space we take a look at some
of the more family friendly games around
this Christmas if you're lucky you have
been given a shiny new gadget of some
description this Christmas although
Santa says there is no chance i'll be
getting that Ferrari I asked for I must
be on the naughty list again if you're
not quietly swearing whilst trying to
work out how your new laptop what
chances are you'll either be skyping
granny in Australia or instagramming
your sprites technology is transforming
our lives but how is it changing
Christmas skies Katie Spencer it's been
finding out hey do you like the iPad
what do you like about it wanting to get
our hands on all the latest gadgets and
gizmos that Christmas is nothing new
really long gone are the days of having
a lump of coal in a stocking but in the
last few years our lives have become
increasingly more plugged into
technology social media now dominates
how we communicate so at a time when
families are meant to come together are
we in danger of losing the spirit of
Christmas certainly with smartphones and
being you know link to Facebook and
Twitter and all these different digital
social media platforms that
communication that happens across a
dinner table and that coming together as
a family is disrupted by technology have
we taken our tech obsession too far
counting our Christmas dinner calories
with a smart fork or waging war on the
neighbors with our very own drone also
out this year there's the ipotty
combining toilet training with a
built-in tablet stand a step too far for
some but this year an increasing
number of companies are trying to work
with children's curiosity by integrating
learning games with the latest
technology children emulate what their
parents do and whether we like it or not
we'll use tablets now we all use
smartphones and children want to be
involved in that will you playing jazz
for the first time this year's sales of
tablet computers are likely to have
overtaken pcs although that's been an
early Christmas present to high street
retailers one of the biggest causes of
arguments over the festive period is
likely to be figuring out how it all
works if I want a high level it's
because you've played on my tab and
upgraded your levels one solution amazon
kindle has come up with is it's made a
service thank you for pressing the
Mayday button how can I help you whoa no
need to shout as a loved one instead
they promised someone can calmly explain
what you need to do and I expect ya on
Christmas morning we will be having a
lot of arguments about how do i register
this kindle or how do i set up this ipad
properly but hopefully this year a
little better than the last year all
tech companies have to focus really hard
on making their products easy to use
because they want more people to buy
them not just the gadget hardcore it's
estimated parents will have spent over
three billion pounds on the latest
gadgets for kids this year well that may
mean a bumper stocking for some taking
the time to switch off from technology
might be a trickier matter altogether
hey to Spencer Sky News you're watching
swype coming up we meet the astronauts
ton singer commander Chris Hadfield but
first now I don't know about you but
I've often thought what I really want is
a miniature version of myself and not
just because this suit has something of
a squeezed middle a room full of many
Me's brilliants or maybe creeping I'm
not too sure well through the magic of
3d printing a london-based company is
helping people to create models of
themselves so rather than glamorous old
me we sent skies Gemma Morris to give it
a try if you're stuck for any last
minute Christmas
gift ideas here's a totally unique
suggestion for you I'm a selfridges in
central London at the pop-up I make a
store where they've got a 3d photo booth
customers get inside and have about 50
photos taken from every angle and it
should lead to the creation of one of
these a little six-inch figurine a mini
you now the man running it all here is
Sylvain hello silver now I'm gonna have
a go in the booth yes what can I expect
what's about to happen to me you're
gonna get scanned by all our cameras and
after a little while we print you in the
figurine pretty much like this one does
it resemble now how is this printed what
kind of technology decision we use a
professional printer printing on a
powder with color it is not painted at
all it's printed just like you are it's
gonna be an exact replica of me then yes
that's it Sylvain assures me that once
inside the booth or shout out
instructions telling me to stay
perfectly still goodbye look by how it's
very bright is a bit like being in a
sunbed as my body is captured in 360
degrees I can't help but wonder how many
people would really want to see
themselves in 3d plastic and pay 159
pounds for the privilege can I change my
position a couple of minutes later I
leave the booth and pick the best of
three options it may be cutting-edge
technology but that doesn't mean you can
escape age-old photobooth pitfalls the
classic eyes closed shot for example but
when you've chosen images you're happy
with the details are sent to I makers 3d
printing center in another part of
London and in just a few days time my
mini plastic clones should be delivered
to Sky News HQ and here it is my 3d
printed mini me
Wow well it's got a kind of a green hue
to it but I guess that's a pretty good
likeness it's kind of surreal looking at
yourself in six-inch plastic but the
detail is quite remarkable you can even
see the nail varnish on my fingertips
strands of hair and detail even on my
face where my makeup is the collar on my
shirt even my shoes to even my
fingertips although I've got to say I
still don't know who I would give this
to as a Christmas present it would have
to be somebody who really loves me maybe
my mom perhaps you're watching smite
coming up we take a look at one of the
smallest drones on the market but first
commander Chris Hadfield he has to have
been one of the most talked-about people
of 2013 the Canadian astronaut became
famous for tweeting breathtaking images
of the Earth's surface from onboard the
International Space Station and if that
wasn't enough he even managed to record
a cover of David Bowie's Space Oddity
from space ground control to Major Tom
he is clearly one of the coolest men on
the planet and above it now he's back on
earth we managed to catch up with them I
flew in space three times and use the
best of the technology on board but this
last flight five months with the
invention of social media gave me a
chance to share it like like never
before to not only be able to widely
distribute say a picture take a picture
of whatever of I don't know the firth up
north of edinboro take a picture and
within minutes send it to the world so
that everyone in the UK could see it but
also everyone around the world and even
more importantly could respond back
hundreds of thousands of people could
sort of of their own volition come on
board that sharing of a new human
experience which is what social media is
all about the sharing of human
experience was a wonderful invention for
something like spaceflight
when I recorded it the genius of Bowie
was evident in that it affected the
place affected how I sang the song and i
loved how just the vocal sound it
surprised me and that then led to my
friends putting some instrumentals
underneath and then with permission from
Bowie to videotape it on board and then
my son and an editor to put together the
final product mm Greiner put the music
underneath and now it's I mean it's been
seen just the the one video that my son
made that posted to his website has been
seen almost 20 million times and with
the rebroadcast of course it's hundreds
of millions of times around the world
that that's been seen and even even
though he himself said it was I think
the best cover ever so immense praise
for something that was really just kind
of a father-son project
you're watching swype coming up a few
family pleasers in this week's games
review but first he has a roundup of
anything you might have missed over the
last few days Thank of a drawn and you
picture something fairly big right check
this out the robot dragonfly invented by
a team of dutch researchers it's one of
the smallest lightest drones on the
market and can detect obstacles as it
flies the dell fly navigates using
flapping wings onboard cameras and a
tiny computer one of its uses could be
inspecting unsafe buildings Nelson
Mandela was the most popular Google
search in 2013 following his death
earlier this month millions of people
logged on to find out more about the
anti-apartheid leader gadgets were also
popular with searches for the iphone 5s
and Samsung's Galaxy s4 both making the
top 10 can't be bothered to drive to see
your relatives this Christmas well this
is Ford solution let the car do all the
hard work this is the snappily titled
automated fusion hybrid research vehicle
ford's hope to get in on the
self-driving car market it uses lider
infrared light sensors to you and me to
produce a 3d map of the area around it
which is apparently sort of how dolphins
use sound waves just don't try to take
it for a swim the virtual currency
Bitcoin has dramatically fallen in value
after China's biggest trading platform
band deposits in yuan at its peak
Bitcoin traded at seven hundred and
sixty four pounds but on Wednesday one
Bitcoin was valued at just 389 pounds
two weeks ago China told financial
institutions to stop providing Bitcoin
related services and products warning it
could be used for illegal activities and
talking a Bitcoin so do you fancy making
over 120,000 pounds worth of the virtual
currency that's the reward being offered
by telegram a secure messaging service
our confidence in its security the
company has set hackers the challenge it
will publish encrypted telegram traffic
on its website between the company's
founders Pavel and Nikolai do love the
winner will have to be able to recover a
secret email address you're basting the
turkey for the 10th time the kids are
running wild what can you do well
no further we asked our all-knowing
expert keza McDonald to recommend a few
games that should keep everyone quiet
paralyzed onions engage digital book
this that's me faecium is an excellent
game to play with as a family if you
have more than one iphone or ipad
basically it makes you the captain of a
spaceship and everybody who's playing
with you is also running the spaceship
with you so it gives you commands you
end up saying ridiculous things like
install the flibbertigibbet or wipe the
windscreen and you have to say what
you're doing and then the other player
has to do it on their screen it requires
a men's coordination it's usually
totally chaotic after a while everyone
just ends up shouting over each other so
really it's ideal for Christmas star
wall is a ridiculous premise imagine
you're a narwhal and you're in space and
all of your friends and family are also
in space and are also narwhals and
you're fighting each other to pierce
each other's hearts with your big long
Narwhal noses it's ridiculous fun you
can play the demo for free on the PC the
full version will be out later in the
year but for now all you really need is
a pc at least two people and about ten
minutes to have a good time rayman
legends has up to four players it's a
really colorful beautiful platformer
it's very creative as well it's
especially good to play with younger
members of a family at Christmas but
it's got enough going on to keep older
older family members entertained as well
my favorite family game for Christmas is
definitely super mario 3d world you
might not have a Wii U but there's a
really good reason to own one
Super Mario 3d World is ridiculously
inventive it's gorgeous colorful it's
got classic Mario platforming it's
excellent fun for little kids but it's
better fun I think if you're playing it
as a family with some people who are
older and some people who are younger
because you can all help each other out
the great thing about the game though is
that sometimes it's cooperative and
sometimes it's competitive so you're
switching every minute between fighting
each other and helping each other right
yeah well that's a lot for this week
remember you can catch up with the
breaking text or you saw a week on Sky
News for iPad or smartphone apps and sky
news com we'll see you next time